kleiner Schneemann großer Schneemann
richtig lecker schmeckt
[Musik]
anders
[Gelächter]
zeige machen Vanillekipferl ich will
keine kipferlform das sind ja alles
bisschen
einfach so lange im Kühlschrank deswegen
weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
gut
kadaverficker 11. Dezember ist oder
DHL-Paket zu schnell
[Musik]
natürlich
kleiner Schneemann großer Schneemann die
sind die
Kekse
[Musik]
du bist eher so die Motive ne also
Weihnachtsmann Schneemann
oder so zwischendurch in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei
[Musik]
Mandarinen Pause
[Applaus]
kommt ihr raus wenn ich mir noch mal ich
liebe christmas-songs machen wirklich
[Musik]
zeige meine letzten bisschen noch sieht
das bei dir ich weiß gar nicht was ich
[Musik]
so und während du
am Station vorbereitet hier haben wir
Farb Farbtuben und Zuckerguss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
benutze ich gerade jetzt mein Tannenbaum
gell okay
ich habe mir diesen lustiger hier
vorgestellt ich was was was was was
[Musik]
deine Chiquita Banane sich geworden
[Applaus]
Deichmann
[Musik]
dies ist nicht mein Job hier kommt schon
raus
[Musik]
Putzstein
modernes Haus moderne Häuser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da kann man nichts falsch machen kann
[Musik]
die sind so extrem geilen Polizisten